6 24 here it's a Monday morning the
Asian American Pacific Islander
Community it's one of our fastest
growing populations in the valley and
later this month there's a conference to
highlight contributions to Southern
Nevada so here to talk about the
uplifted conference Maggie II the
founder and CEO of the Asian hustle
Network so before Maggie we talk about
the conference tell me about Asian
hustle Network you guys launched right
before the pandemic and have just
exploded but you started on Facebook yes
Facebook yes I know it's it's pretty
crazy we had no idea it was going to
grow this big but we knew it was going
to be big we wanted to build a community
that would uplift and support the Asian
entrepreneurial community and initially
we wanted to create a space where people
could share their entrepreneurial
stories connect with each other support
each other ask questions offer help and
within the first two years we've
garnered to over 200 000 members wow and
it's such a network in the Asian
community in Las Vegas all ready to put
it on social media certainly helps let's
talk about the uplifted conf difference
the the mission the goal of what you're
trying to do here yeah so
support Asian entrepreneurial stories
but everyone wanted to meet in person so
that's why we wanted to create a event
in Las Vegas and Las Vegas would have
been the perfect place for events and
everyone was just you know excited to
come to the city and last year we had
about 300 people to attend this year
we're aiming for about 500 to 600 people
and just to create a community and space
where people can share their stories and
we wanted to create a platform for
people to do that now it's still open so
folks can still go next Thursday and
Friday what can they expect if they're
an attendee what will they see speakers
what what kind of events and things are
you offering yeah so it's going to be on
April 27th and 28th from 9am to 6 p.m
and they're going to experience keynote
speakers Workshop sessions where they
can actually go into workshops and you
know get down and dirty learn about the
nitty-gritty of like certain topics and
then there's networking sessions there's
food and drinks we'll have interactive
activities we want people to walk away
from this conference feeling like they
actually learn something I think there's
a lot of conferences and events where
people kind of go to the event but they
don't remember what they've learned and
so we want to create that experience
where they remember okay this was the
keynote speaker this is what I learned
this was a connection that I made and be
able to walk away feeling like they
gained something out of it well Maggie
is such a vital growing part of our
community Asian American Pacific
Islander Community good luck with the
conference uh good luck and thanks for
joining us we appreciate the time thank
you so much yes we'll put all this
information folks on the website but
again it's next week Thursday and Friday
thank you thank you stick around we'll
be right back